am I gonna get a nice mesh thing um you
have oh no high school fashion baby I
really don't know how high schoolers
dress these days what's a septum they're
doing things that I still to this day
I'm not confident enough to do are you
ready yeah we have four amazing diverse
high school girls who sent in their
dream vision of how they want their high
school male counterparts to dress and to
bring their business to life we've
brought in a designer he's gonna make us
all five oh yeah nothing like a bunch of
30 year old man getting dressed up by a
little girl
[Music]
it's high school makeover time how do
high schoolers dress now I'm gonna just
cool like Jack give me your Jack get
over here they just wear like a lot more
patterns but everything's like tight
this is what high schoolers look like
he's got the cool hair
the Ned's trying to have so a lot of
like high-waisted hip type short things
he's got this like half tuck I every
time I try to have to up my shirt I look
like a [ __ ] they do like the button all
the way sometimes they put things
together that I just don't understand
and I admire it in a lot of ways I don't
know what are these old VHS tapes I
don't know you know I have to know they
are because they're hot explain to me
how a cassette works Jack go sit down
today when a trend happens you
immediately know what happens because of
the inner dog I had that in the 2000s
but we had to wait a year by the time we
wore it it was not cool anymore jack has
proved that high schoolers dress really
well now at least the ones who have the
hair like yeah the way that I dressed in
high school kind of existed up until
like two years ago my jeans were always
way too long this was coming out of the
days where baggy jeans were cool I just
didn't get the memo that everyone else
had moved on I wasn't cool enough to
skateboard so I wore the skateboard and
clothes and then I wasn't funny enough
to be funny so I put jokes on myself all
the things that I wanted to be but
didn't know how to be because I was an
insecure young boy my style in high
school was a lot of baggy polo shirts I
think it was because I was kind of
skinny like if I wore a tight shirt I
would just look like it what chicken
only recently after I got married where
Ariel would kind of help me find things
that she found more attractive so I
wouldn't say I truly became fashionable
until I was 29 year old yeah I was last
year I was a geeky nerd I played French
horn played Magic the Gathering there
wasn't on brand for me to look good
I dressed real funny I I just dressed
like outfits were meant to be jokes
it didn't seem my girls like me so I
didn't want to give him a reason to it
worked I could say I succeeded in
repelling all women for a long time in
my life I was kind of dressing in
ever I thought was styling which was
highly dominated by a lot of Justin
Timberlake going solo
I look back my photos and I'm like kill
it with fire I did not look cool I were
a lot of scarves on t-shirt lot of man
jory one ring one bracelet dog tags dog
tag refuse we were all nerds in high
school and I think in the end we just
want to look cool so I know these girls
gonna want to get their hands on Draya
that there's a she says a lot of people
I'm gonna try and lock that in Leah's
glasses matching necklace this is great
I love her hair color already a good
sign I mean look at your high school
kitchen is now from the pictures I'm
seeing that new cams thank you shirt
thank you everything
okay I get it you know I was bagging
baby baby baby the sizing these pants
the lane look at these pictures
she's smiling but she hates it I just
had one pair of shoes there are shoes
for everything like not one pair for
everything I do like the second picture
I'm just admiring the glass Thanksgiving
why this is me on a plate I really don't
know what to say when you walked in
whether it's a good or a bad way you
left me at a loss for words your clothes
don't fit you I guess
[Music]
it just looks like you're trying to
figure out who you are but you don't
really know this right
yikes
10 top and chains flip-flop combo the
common that we don't need to bring back
into the world
Marly associated I love it the deep 50
paired with the gravest true icon I
always applaud accessorizing and you you
went there that's scarf I would just say
don't ever do that again
sorry Marley yikes I'm sorry these looks
that the high schoolers brought are
gonna be really really really amazing
what my thought is it is rock'n'roll
sort of grunge direction myself and I
want to keep the Train myself
she wants rock and roll I can do this
like close bro wait Cole Sprouse from
Zack and Cody
I'm only of that sweet life he's very
naughty Jackie and the messy stuff messy
hair attacks a bad boy style I chose for
Ned was pretty spooky to be a rookie I
really wanted to look straight out of
the nylon magazine she's gonna make me
extra I'm gonna do some oversized pieces
highways maybe about moment oversized
high waist it sounds like pajamas am I
gonna be wearing pajamas um denim
pajamas still trying to achieve that
arts you live in it I could definitely
stand be a little more artsy all of this
hair is gonna be brushed to the front
I think ears as a lot about how it was
in a once hello so I guess my hair says
that I don't care about anything
style we have chosen for you is a
horrifying minimalistic sweet chic look
there are seven adjutant Zin that it
still follows the current trend of high
school guys but with a more refined
grown-up taste you are probably gonna be
the most fashion-forward of the try guys
today well that is not a lot of all that
guard is coming into trends like aw
Anderson and the style I'm kind of
looking for is more in endogenous queer
fashion as we see rainbow flags right on
I wanted to have possibly more of a
masculine clothing type but have like
makeup in hair with her look we are
going all the way hmm
I don't know how often Eugenia's to
dyeing his hair oh well not that open
damn are you ready I think I want to
have you try this on Wow a plastic
jacket whoa whoa moment I'm gonna start
describing my clothes for the moment
everything is a moment oh my god I'm
having a moment what's on the back more
scorpions Milo I'm a bad boy it makes my
my stupid outfit look like oh he's got a
point gear he's trying to make yeah it's
pretty cool get the will of the Asian
ancestors before you
we're good with little feet why do I
feel like I'm about to invade Normandy
this is cooler than anything I own and
this is not because I need the glasses
no this is strictly fashion it's cuz I
want the globe
I'm into this a little fun dirty it has
processors on it it has crosses oh no
I'm Jewish right but we might not go
with this one and I mean if we've
removed all of this I'm just a traffic
cone that tried to dress like a human
this is what people wear I've seen
things like this in the store but I'm
just always afraid that
[Music]
out of it and weird ways some people
like hair some people it's a choice it
is a moment B no one should have a
badass she wants everyone to look badass
nice a happy lady her palate that she's
stuck way exactly I'm excited for her
vision because I think any vision is
better than this me somehow no I'm good
I'm just gonna walk on out here Keith
what you know number five Denisha he's
bad boys I didn't do that and I have no
doubt about you pull it off welcome to
the sweet life you look like a bad boy
who lost 70 pounds I'd give him my lunch
money like old zach is miiverse the guy
if you told me not to worry about nice
meme reference I love the jacket I love
the shirt the rings are overwhelming to
me I like this I think Deena's version
of you rocks this story I'm still
handling the length of the pants I got
you really cold sprout stuff the Dylan
died who are these people there are
pieces in this outfit that I either own
or try to own so like I'm on the right
track to being a high schooler I look
like the guy that would make out with
your prom date which is a nice role
reversal if someone else made out with
my prom date in front of me let's talk
about this this is a very realistic
version of a cool guy in high school
today I'm a bad foil that boy look that
boy bad boy we need to stop this now
thank you yeah I'm gonna join the pen15
Club yeah I love the penis clip you ever
know like Penn Island penis land we can
mix the nose rings no no no it's
essential and he's gonna have black
nails because his style has a lot of ink
but I know school is meaningless from
behind I don't think you are I just know
I want to sleep with you can lime hair
is great septum piercing actually looks
really hard the coat is gorgeous and
like just the colors across the outfit
are amazing you look like a really hot
artistic lesbian mom
snaps to that if you went to high school
with me though I wouldn't know what to
do with myself let me be clear Zach I
would definitely not be your friend you
do kind of suck now too
oh yeah this is such a look I've never
seen matches with nail polish on a guy
and it's incredible every item you're
wearing your wife could borrow I'm a
trendsetter I certainly would never have
chosen this for myself but now that I
see it I just can't wait to get into
Oxford and start my real life I bless
you and I respect you
class dismissed sober still got two
makeovers are you done yet Eugene I'm
doing what breathing what breathing yeah
all right you ready to get dressed up
the school I'm so ready honestly you
should feel badass and cool what yeah
the guys are gonna be so jealous I
you could totally pull it off as long as
you got the confidence and you feel
great in it I think this look deserves
some extra credit you are having an
orange oh joy look like a sexy traffic
cone yeah yeah you don't look like a
traffic cone but you would stop traffic
that was good I've never seen you wear
boots those pants are beautiful yeah
these pants are amazing no I definitely
didn't think I would like it and do you
yeah everything about this is pretty
it's done it you look like a very
fashionable Japanese person yes that's
what it is right it makes sense because
this is the most fashion-forward in
Japan as always like three and a half
seasons ahead of us this is just the
coolest version of yourself you come
back to the states Jack how do I look
honestly you do pull it off yeah [ __ ]
little [ __ ]
what a shitty thing because that's great
this is a beautiful moment and I just
want us to all appreciate that all three
of us look way better than you James
yeah Jane looks terrible you know I know
some really great ramen spots if you
ever want me to show I know ramen spots
hmm Sakura have you ever read Hemingway
I don't really don't first thing we're
gonna do is take off all these
accessories I plead those first dressing
androgynous is such a beautiful thing
who the fish that's up over your shirt
over the shirt having been wearing some
fantastically feminine person would wear
hopefully it would open a new avenue of
style for him because he does seem very
confident
[Music]
excuse me is this the nurse's office
because this look is sickening Wow very
like entrancing I find it very beautiful
and I don't understand this
oh my god you have double ear piercings
now you're wearing makeup and it works
also you have the giant boots on and
then your hair just goes straight up
it's like you're seven people Wow I
can't be a bad boy when I miss little
this is a cool jacket it's got some
really great details on it so fluid I'm
torn on the fishnets on the leg yeah
there are high-waisted fishnet do I look
like Tilda Swinton Rihanna had an Asian
baby I feel the Tilda I see you Tilda
everything at Tilda moment instead it
was gonna be an androgynous look I
expected it to be more foreign tonight I
think anyone could wear that yeah nice
will you try to stand out you're trying
to find who you are and you're trying to
use your fashion who you're developing
your personality to have this strong of
a look it's such a statement we're all
those types of boys out there ready to
experiment you got four new looks to
play with and they only cost $30,000 Sal
is so individual and is such a deep
expression of oneself that many times a
lot people say they don't have style but
I think it's just that they haven't
found it we were lucky to find four
young girls who have found their style
and shared with us throughout my life
there have been things that wasn't
confident enough to wear and that's not
a high school exact thing that's just
hug always today has shown me that that
is a restriction that I put on myself do
it for how it makes you feel and how it
like affects your personality
maybe when you do see that side of the
box you could be rewarded for it I think
it's all about just surprising people
with how you look I was doing it with a
negative way but you can surprise people
by looking cool it's still just as
effective there's a lot of things that
we might be wearing that you might not
be personally comfortable with but
someone out there is and I think that's
what's important if you're a cool high
school if you don't dress like this that
is okay but the fact that some high
schoolers take like this is amazing grab
some your friends close for month if you
look hotter than them Jack can you see
me Explo school's out for summer boys
all right I hate school at the end of
the summer I realized the world hadn't
changed I changed
[Music]
you